night but we definitely wish and
congratulate the rams uh all the all the
best from the city and the city of la
for sure okay
so this is something that uh that just
went out so just in case you guys all
you all didn't get it yet so president
biden spoke today with prime minister
boris johnson of the united kingdom
the leaders discussed their recent
diplomatic engagements with ukraine and
russia
they also reviewed ongoing diplomatic
and deterrence efforts in response to
russia's continued military buildup on
ukraine's borders and reaffirmed their
support for ukraine sovereignty and
territorial integrity they discussed
efforts to reinforce the defensive
posture on nato's eastern flank and
underlying the continued close
coordination among allies and partners
including
on readiness to impose severe
consequences on russia should it choose
further military escalation so i have a
few more things for all of you at the
top
today marks four years since the
parkland shooting as the president said
this morning in a statement that i'm
sure all of you have seen
we can never bring back
those we've lost but we can't come
together to fulfill the first
responsibility of our government and our
democracy to keep each other safe for
parkland for all those we've lost
and for all those left behind it is time
to uphold that solemn obligation
since his first day in office the
president has worked to uphold
that obligation and to save lives by
preventing gun violence
he again called on congress this morning
to act including to expand background
checks to keep criminals from getting
guns
and to ban the sort of high capacity
magazines that were used to kill two
nypd officers and the president called
again on congress to fulfill his budget
requests for another half billion
dollars to fight gun violence but if
congress won't act the president
president's not going to just wait and
sit back he's already done more than any
other president in their first year in
history to advance common sense gun
violence prevention measures and he
built
on that just earlier this month with new
measures he announced in new york city
last june he laid out a comprehensive
strategy to address gun violence from
every angle and the white house is
working closely with agencies across the
administration to deliver on that and
save lives
the plan is comprehensive
addressing both the supply and demand
side
contributors of to gun violence pursuing
prevention
intervention and accountability using
every tool
in the toolkit regulation enforcement
budget the bully pulpit and legislation
and pulling together the federal
agencies for a whole of government
effect effort to reduce gun violence
specifically we're addressing the root
causes of gun violence by expanding
educational and economic opportunities
or we're going after especially
dangerous firearms with new proposed
regulations on ghost guns and stabilize
stabilizing braces that turn pistols
into rifles
we're stepping up federal law
enforcement efforts against illegal gun
trafficking including through strike
forces in major cities and establishing
a zero tolerance policy for gun dealers
who willfully sell guns illegally
and we're providing cities and states
with unprecedented amounts of money
including through the rescue plan
to invest in community policing and
effective community violence
intervention intervention programs and
aft
during an event at the white house today
vice president kamala harris announced
alongside fcc chairwoman rose
rosenwarsel and senior advisor mitch
landrieu that more than 10 million
households are enrolled in the
affordable connectivity program the
nation's largest ever broadband
affordability program created through
the bipartisan infrastructure law the
affordability connectivity program
enables
low-income households to apply for
discounts towards monthly internet
service
and a one-time discount on tech
equipment such as laptops or computers
this is one of the many ways that the
biden harris administration is ensuring
every american has access to reliable
affordable high-speed internet
the bipartisan infrastructure law
delivers an a historic and historic 65
billion dollars to ensure that every
american has access to reliable
high-speed internet through through an
historic investment in broadband
infrastructure
development that intent that internet
service is affordable by lowering costs
increasing competition and creating
price transparency with that
please go ahead darlene thank you a
couple of questions on ukraine and then
one on another topic um what is the
reaction here to the kremlin
signaling that it's ready to continue
dialogue over ukraine and does the white
house see that as a sincere on the part
of the russians so
yeah
i thank you for the question we are
actively working
to reach a diplomatic solution to
de-escalate the crisis over the weekend
as you all know the president
spoke with with president putin and we
remain engaged with the russian
government in full coordination with our
allies and partners the path for
diplomacy remains available if russia
chooses to engage constructively
however we are clear-eyed about the
prospects of that given
the steps russia is taking on the ground
in plain sight this is something that
the national security adviser jake
sullivan talked about right here on
friday uh right before our eyes what
we're seeing um with russia new russian
we're seeing new russian forces have
been arriving at the ukrainian
border every day
as we have said before we're in the
window
when an invasion could begin at any time
we will not comment on any details of
our intelligence information except that
except to say that it could begin this
week despite a lot of speculation that
it would happen after the olympics again
something that uh jake sullivan said
right here on friday it remains unclear
which path russia will choose to take
the u.s is ready for any uh situation
you know president biden has made it
very clear on his call with putin this
weekend that if russia undertakes a
further invasion
of ukraine the united states together
with our allies and partners will
respond decisively and impose swift and
severe costs on russia
president biden reiterated that a
further russian invasion of
ukraine would produce widespread human
suffering and diminish russia's standing
so we are continuing to coordinate
closely with our allies and partners
president biden spoke with president
zielinski yesterday and prime minister
boris johnson as i just read out to you
that call
this this afternoon and we are in close
contact with our allies again and
partners again across all levels of
government
our partnership with our european and
nato allies have never been stronger
and purposeful as we were collectively
to de-escalate the tensions at the
ukraine russia border if russia should
choose to invade the severe economic
consequences
and and irrevocable revocable
reputational damage caused by taking
innocent lives for a bloody war
will only weaken the country not
strengthen it
in that close coordination with allies
and partners
is the view that russia's willingness
what they say today about wanting to
continue the dialogue
is is there a consensus that is that
that is sincere i mean how do all of you
interpret what's coming out of the
kremlin today so we've been very clear
about this um there is only one country
who is currently building up uh their
forces
at the ukraine border and that's russia
and as we have stated as jake sullivan
has stated
that we in the past 10 days or so we
only continue to see a build up not a
de-escalation
so we are open
to diplomacy that door to diplomacy is
open as we have said
and and so that is what were
that's what we want to be headed towards
and uh you know if
we we will be ready uh for whichever
decision that president putin decides
but clearly we would we would prefer the
path of diplomacy i also want to just
say one more thing really quickly uh
this is something that
my
colleague kirby said john kirby said at
the department of defense just now that
secretary austin is going to travel to
belgium poland and lithuania so that you
all have this
the secretary is going to meet with
allied defense ministers and nato
leadership to discuss russia's military
buildup
in and around ukraine reiterate the u.s
commitment to article 5 and continue the
alliance's progress on deterrence and
defense while ensuring the alliance is
prepared to face uh tomorrow's
challenges
in two weeks the president is going to
go up to the capital to deliver his
first state of the union message
can you give us a status report on uh
preparations for that uh has he been
able to meet with his advisors on it
given everything that's going on or
edits these drafts or just some sort of
idea of where that process starts so as
you know this is a president who was
vice president for eight years and he
was senator uh for 36 years and has
spent a lot of time listening to state
of the union speeches so he understands
the importance of delivering such a a
president delivering such a impactful
speech
and the
the purpose of uh talking about their
successes his success in particular this
past year and how he's going to build on
that success i don't have anything more
to share but this is something that's
important to him and and uh he's working
towards delivering a speech not just to
the uh not just to congress but also to
the american public
russia's foreign today that russia keep
pursuing diplomatic negotiations this is
a yes or no question does this
administration view that as a sign of
de-escalation
well
what i was saying and just to be even
clearer is that in the past 10 days or
so when you look at
what is happening at the border of
ukraine
uh there we are seeing more than a
hundred thousand uh troops there and
it's just been an everyday uh more and
more troops as i just read out at the
top uh so we are certainly open to uh to
having conversations and uh and seeing a
de-escalation uh but uh right now
this is uh that door is open for
diplomacy uh and this is up to president
putin he has to make that decision it is
his decision to make on which direction
uh he wants to take this so in terms of
the troop build up there there's
reporting today that a uf citing a u.s
official that russian units near ukraine
moved into attack positions is that the
the understanding of this administration
what you're seeing there well um i'm not
going to go into uh any intelligence
information
we're not clear we're not going to share
that but
what we have seen and
you know the national security advisor
said this himself
we have seen an increase
of forces at the border
not a decrease
and
and so what we are saying to uh
president putin with our european allies
and partners we've been working in
coordination in lockstep uh for these
past several weeks several months
is that that door to diplomacy is is
open
and uh and um having that diplomatic
conversation is is a path that we would
like to take and finally lastly uh jake
sullivan came out here and certainly got
the attention of the entire world with
the urgency of the briefing that he gave
on friday in terms of the current state
right now
is the situation as eminent today right
now as it was on friday you know um
jake sullivan was also on the sunday
shows yesterday and uh you know again we
are in the window when an invasion could
begin at any time uh you know we're
again i'm not gonna comment on the
intelligence information uh except to
say that it could begin this week uh
despite a lot of speculation that it
would only happen after the olympics
um that's correct um just to follow up
on that um i understand you're saying
that you've only seen a troop buildup
but russia has claimed today that it is
winding down a number of military drills
and exercises that have caused concern
are you in a position to confirm if
those claims are accurate or if they're
not i'm not in a position to to uh to
confirm that but i do know john kirby
spoke to that just moments ago so i
would refer you to his comments and the
department of defense okay um and
specifically uh about um you know
ukraine and the vatican we have some
reporting coming from there saying
ukraine has um
welcomed vatican mediation of this
conflict with russia and they've invited
the pope uh to visit the country as soon
as possible is the president aware of
that does he support such efforts i mean
i i have not spoken to the president
about that so i i can't uh i can't
confirm if he's aware or not okay will
the administration support such efforts
i this is the first time i'm hearing
about it so i just need to talk to our
team okay and one more on the one
billion dollar loan guarantee that the
us has agreed to make available to
support the ukrainian economy
our reporting shows that
the us will need about 200 million
dollars to guarantee that loan um do you
does the administration need to make
more uh appropriate appropriations
available to sort of you know make sure
that loan guarantee program works so i
don't have the specifics on on that
piece but i can confirm that it is
something we are considering as part of
the additional uh microeconomic support
we are exploring to help ukraine's
economy a pressure resulting from
russia's military buildup but i i don't
have any specifics on the appropriation
and what that would take the process
okay the u.s support some statements
from the ukrainians that they're no
longer actively pursuing nato membership
would they be willing to stall the
pursuit of nato membership as part of
our negotiations
well as you know uh
naval membership nato has an open door
policy that is not something that is
something that ukraine will have to
decide on its own uh that is not
something that we are in consultation
with or make you know or even uh decide
on that is something that nato and and
has to decide on and ukraine that's up
to them and their leadership on how they
want to move forward um jake yesterday
said that the two leaders uh presidents
putin and biden tasked their teams for
continuing
uh to talk or discuss kind of the state
of play do you have any idea kind of the
construct of those discussions of what
they entail um and opinion have occurred
since the discussion on saturday i do
believe uh jake sullivan had a
a
a conversation this morning with uh with
uh
what one of our one of our european
partners and allies between the russians
oh
russia oh i see i see uh i don't have
anything to i don't have anything to
read out or predict and and do you mean
on the on on the staff level or do you
mean like under the principal level yeah
under the principle i don't have
anything to read out as you know our our
staff here has been in constant contact
with russia ukraine and our nato allies
as well one last one um there's concern
in terms of uh obviously in the european
uh economic side of things if russia
continues to escape an invasion on the
domestic side of things is the white
house economic team looking at anything
that the president may need to pursue if
an invasion
comes to pass about what it could do
obviously oil markets being one but i
think just general instability and
markets yeah i don't have anything
specific to read out to you for you at
this moment as we talk about energy i'm
assuming that's one of the things that
you're uh you're asking about phil is
like we are working with countries and
companies around the world to ensure the
security of supply and to mitigate
against price shocks affecting the
american people europe and the global
economy
we are continuing our discussions with
major producers around
around the globe to supply
so supply meets demand all tools are on
the table uh a disruption in physical
energy supplies trans trans trans
transiting
ukraine would most accurately affect
natural gas markets in europe and so we
are engaging our european allies to
coordinate response planning including
how to deploy their existing energy
stockpiles we have been working to
identify additional volumes of
non-russian natural gas from north
africa in the middle east to asia and
the us
we we thank we think
we thank reint comments by japan about
supporting europe's energy
security through lng shipments to the
region we are in discussion with major
natural gas producers around the globe
to understand their capacity and
willingness to temporarily surge natural
gas output and to allocate these volumes
in european buyers we are also engaging
with major buyers and suppliers of lng
to ensure flexibility in existing
contracts and storage
is is managed and enables a diver
diversion
reporting
uh according ukrainian officials are
saying that president zielinski's
statement today that the invasion is
imminent on february 16th
was in fact
sarcastic or ironic and more of a
commentary on this idea that there are
countries or entities that know of a
date certainly uh is that sarcasm or
irony
the read of the nsc in the white house
so i i i don't have a read on that
here's what i can tell you about about
that i
i heard i heard the the statement but i
haven't actually heard it in a full
context so the irony of all of it i have
i couldn't speak to but i will say this
well i'm not going to speak to
intelligence matters as i've said
multiplies what multiplies already
our intelligence or intelligence sharing
with the ukraines ukrainians as we said
before we are in the window when an
invasion could begin at any time it
remains unclear which path russia will
choose to take because we do not know it
is his decision to make we remain
engaged with russian government in full
coordination with our allies and
partners the path for diplomacy remains
available if russia chooses to engage
again constructively but we are
clear-eyed about the prospects on the
ground and are ready to impose severe
costs on russia in coordination with our
allies and partners if they attack
ukraine
two other unrelated matters supreme
court is it still
the expectation that the president will
interview nominees this week and do
those that are under consideration
know for certain that they're on
the short list of people being
considered
so you know i appreciate the interest
here um
look um you know after having a series
of conversations and good discussions
with lawmakers uh from both
both sides of the party legal expert
scholars last week the president
continued to review materials as he
considers deeply
deeply qualified candidates as we have
said with strong experience character
integrity dedication to the constitution
and the rule of law i don't have
anything else to share on any interviews
or who he's interviewed
but
you know we we don't have anything else
to share for today or for this week
what's that
has he interviewed someone then the way
you just
said interview yeah
oh i'm sorry i meant to be he has not
interviewed potential nominees to be
clear sorry
um but uh but to just answer your last
question is that we are on track he is
on track to select a uh scotus nominee
uh by the end of this month um and then
just real quick robert uh
calif is there caleb who's still
awaiting confirmation in the senate to
be fda commissioner it looks like that
may happen tomorrow
uh is the white house confident he's got
the votes
have you line up all the democratic
votes
well i'll say this we are we are
confident dr calif uh will be confirmed
with bipartisan support uh and urged the
senate to confirm him tomorrow as you
just stated ed it is critically
important to have confirmed leadership
at the fda in the midst of a pandemic as
we all we all know
he had a strong bipartisan showing
coming out of committee including from
ranking member burr it's important to
remember he was confirmed 89 to 4 in
2016 many folks who supported him
then are still in the senate we are in
we are in a daily contact with aj says
who is leading the effort to get him
confirmed hhs and the white house
officials are making a lot of calls to
the hill uh figuring out which means
need need what information which members
need what information secretary becerra
our la ola team and steve verschetti are
all making calls in support of calif to
a bipartisan group of senate offices dr
calif himself has met
has met or is scheduled to meet with 47
senators and that number continues to
increase it's also one of the highest
number of meetings of any nominees that
have been done thus far
in his conversation with president putin
did president biden give him any
signal for how he could de-escalate
would it have to be something visible
like moving forces somewhere could it be
something in the realm of what's verbal
like what we saw from lavrov today is
there anything that the president set
out as a cue that could try to tamp
things down so the call between the two
uh president was professional and
substantive
so it lasted a bit over an hour as you
all know from the readout
this past weekend the two presidents
agreed that our teams would stay engaged
in the days ahead but there was no
fundamental change uh in the dynamic
and just just to close the loop on the
supreme court so
you're not saying that the president has
done any interviews no i'm not i'm not
just to be clear
i meant potential interviews president
has some um travel scheduled this week
given the volatility of world events do
you anticipate that if things were and i
know this is hypothetical but often when
there are
uh
unpredictable events there can be
changes to the schedule are you in a
posture where you think that could be um
a situation where the president would
remain at the white house or anything
like that if things were to change well
as you said it is hard to to read kelly
o a hypothetical or to give an answer to
a hypothetical as you know the president
deals with multiple things at once and
that's what this president is prepared
to do
um
on the sort of ripple effects of
a potential invasion uh is the
administration prepared to block
uh russian oil imports to the us if
russia invades given that the imports
have reached their highest prices in 11
years
so i mean i just laid out what we're
doing we're talking to uh countries and
companies around the world uh engaging
with them on on all the different uh
potential
consequential outcomes if this were to
happen i don't have any more specifics
than that than what i just laid out for
you um and so one of the things that we
have said over and over again and the
president has made this very clear
to vladimir putin is if russia
chooses
to
invade
there will be
swift and severe economic consequences
wouldn't it be difficult though for the
u.s to continue to import russian oil
after all of the rhetoric that we've put
forward
about about russia not needing to not
invade ukraine and pressuring germany to
you know come out strongly
on nordstrom 2 and possible punishments
for russia if they were to take the step
wouldn't it be tough for the u.s to
continue in that event to import russian
gas well again it's it's a hypothetical
i'm just telling you what we have been
very very clear uh the president has
been clear
our national security advisor has been
clear we all have been clear either from
this podium or direct communication
with russia whether it's with the
president or its leadership that if they
were to invade
and in coordination in lockstep with our
european allies and partners that's how
we're moving forward here that there
would be
there would be severe
uh decisive economic consequences i
cannot speak more
to more to that okay and then the um
sanctions package that's being worked
out on capitol hill i understand that
the white house is involved in that
those discussions now and congressional
sources have told me that the white
house has insisted on a waiver from
nordstrom 2 even after an invasion
can you confirm if that is true and if
so why would
the white house want a provision like
that in a sanctions package coming out
of congress well look when it comes to
north stream 2 we've been pretty clear
about this the president has has said
that uh he said this during his press
conference last week uh with the german
chancellor if russia further invades
ukraine uh there will be no longer be a
nordstrom two uh we will bring an end to
it and at this moment nordstrom 2 is not
even operational but is the white house
directing congress to put a waiver from
north street that is the first time
hearing of that i cannot speak to that
i'm just telling you where we have been
in a very strong and definitive way on
nordstrom 2.
second topic this news about a durham
investigation
does the president have any concerns
about a candidate for president
using computer experts to infiltrate
computer systems
of competing candidates or even the
president-elect to use for the goal of
creating a narrative is that something
that that's something i can't speak to
from this podium so i refer you to the
department of
internet
justice
is is that spying again i can't speak to
that report if you i i refer you to
department of justice generally speaking
that with monitoring and internet
traffic i need my answers that i can
change i refer you to department of
justice i can't speak to that from here
okay
thanks um what message does it send
today to the ukrainian government to be
closing the embassy
the embassy in kiev
i know that i know the state department
made an announcement on this earlier
so uh the state department announced
today that they are temporary
temporarily relocating our embassy
operations in ukraine
from our embassy in kiev to lev due to
the dramatic acceleration in the
build-up of russian forces a core team
of embassy staff is remaining in ukraine
to engage
with the ukrainian government
coordinating diplomatic efforts and
diplomacy to de-escalate
the crisis
if the crisis continues so i just wanted
to also say uh this as well because the
state department put out a statement on
this um so the state department has no
higher priority
than the safety and security of
americans around the world and that of
course includes our colleagues serving
at uh at post overseas so these prudent
precautions in no way undermine our
support for our commitment to ukraine
our commitment to ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity is unwavering
we also continue our sincere efforts to
reach a diplomatic solution and we
remain engaged with russian government
following president biden's call with
putin with president putin and
and the secretary's discussion with
foreign minister lavrov the path for
diplomacy remains available if russia
chooses to engage in good faith we look
forward to returning our staff
to the embassy as soon as conditions
permit in the meantime uh we have made
this very clear the national security
adviser jake sullivan has made this
clear the president himself has made
this clear uh that
that these measures for one reason the
safety of our staff as i mentioned we
startingly urge any remaining u.s
citizens in ukraine to leave the country
immediately that has been our message
for the past several days and honestly
the past several weeks does the white
house have any comment on this russian
figure skater who's allowed to compete
as a doping investigation continues
that's not a comment that i'm i'm not
going to comment from here about that i
refer you to the committee the olympic
committee
dc's mayor today announced a
vaccination requirement for some
businesses will be dropped uh tomorrow
and a mass mandate will be dropped by
the end of the month
does the white house support this will
the president the first lady continue to
visit businesses and restaurants as
these will change um so let me just
lay some stuff out for you here because
i know this has been a question that
many have had a number of governors have
announced changes based on conditions in
their particular states
that that's not new uh that isn't new
and so what i can say from here is as dr
fauci has said as a country we are
making strong progress toward moving to
a time when colvin is no longer a crisis
and dr wolinski has has clearly said cdc
is looking at all of their guidance
including mass guidance in light of
declining cases and hospitalizations i
think that may be getting lost in some
of the reporting that we're seeing the
cdc made clear they're looking at their
guidance so just want to make that very
clear but to put a finer point on this
cdc has to move carefully and
deliberately to make sure these good
trends are confirmed across the nation
cdc has a responsibility to make
guidance for the entire country and
everyone they must consider its impact
on a variety of constituencies including
people who are disabled
immunocompromised and most vulnerable we
are spending significant time and energy
on the path forward working with experts
and leaders within and within and
outside the government and if this if
this progress continues we expect
updates in the weeks ahead this is a
huge huge responsibility that we do not
take likely
one that we take very seriously and we
want to make sure that we get this right
thanks kareem um during their
conversation on sunday
uh the president of ukraine reportedly
invited president biden to visit ukraine
in the coming days and the ukrainian
president's office said that a visit by
the u.s president would be a powerful
signal that could contribute to the
de-escalation of this crisis what is the
white house's response to that
investigation uh i don't have any travel
plans to announce or preview at this
time i'll say this you know as you all
know president biden
spoke with zlinski as you just mentioned
this weekend
secretary blanken spoke with the foreign
minister
this morning and we are in regular
contact with the ukrainian government
throughout the administration including
here at the white house at the state
department at the defense department i
just laid out a travel that the
secretary from defense is going to be
making at the treasury department and
elsewhere so the president has has also
dispatched a number of senior
administration officials to visit
ukraine in recent months
including secretary blinken who was just
there recently
and for last month for meetings with
ukraine's leader
our north star has been nothing about
nothing about ukraine without ukraine
you've heard us say this over and over
again and we will continue to coordinate
closely with ukraine as we try to reach
a diplomatic solution to the end of this
crisis
um could i bring you back to the gun
issue that you talked about in the
beginning um a bunch of years ago a
large number of people in about in the
obama administration including the
current president um fought fiercely for
closing the gunshow loophole and
described
it as the least that could be done um
and
were very angry and upset when it didn't
pass um
pushing pushing also
at various times for even more you know
ban on assault weapons
you didn't mention any of that the
president's message today
that he put out earlier didn't mention
any of that is it fair to assume that
either
they no longer this president no longer
thinks those things are needed or has
simply abandoned any hope of getting
them passed
i wouldn't assume that i one of the
things i did say is we are
encouraging congress to act as well
there's a legislation legislative
component to this as you just cut laid
out
so that is important
as well but i do want to read a couple
of quotes
from
about the president's executing on his
historic comprehensive gun violence
reduction strategy so there is
support there for it i know you're
talking about a specific thing but i i
want to not just take our word for this
so brady has called the president's plan
historic and said president biden and
his administration are truly taking
comprehensive action to address violence
in our country
giffords commented the biden harris
administration
commended pardon me the biden
administration
administration for announcing a
comprehensive strategy to prevent gun
violence and protect public safety gun
violence is a complex problem as you can
imagine and as she stated that requires
an array of solutions president biden
and vice president harris understands
that this is a quote from from giffords
every town for gun safety said president
biden is taking the comprehensive
approach we need to address this crisis
and so is there more work to do
absolutely that's why we're encouraging
and urging congress to act as well but
the president's going to do everything
that he can from his perch uh to get
this done he would be satisfied that if
the things that he's pushing
that are on that list and that you have
talked about that he talked about that
would be good enough
we're not calling it good enough he is
doing everything that he can from his
perch uh from the white house from the
federal government and using every tool
that are to our on a true belt that
we've talked about we that's what we try
to do uh to make sure that we're we're
addressing a real problem which is gun
violence uh so what the other part of
that is urging congress to act as well
which we have been doing but he's not
gonna sit back you heard me say that
he's not gonna sit back and wait he's
going to act but they're also not going
to spend a whole lot of time or energy
pushing for a ban on assault weapons or
uh or closing a gun show loophole that
just a bunch of years ago he and others
described as vital
well i'll say this we are constantly in
conversation with folks in congress uh
with leadership uh with congressional
members with senators that is an array
of issues uh the president is going to
continue to fight
uh to make sure that we get these guns
off the street and we truly deal with
gun violence he is doing his part from
the white house and he's going to
continue to work towards that effort
okay thanks corinne a few questions uh
first on afghanistan the fight
administration appears to have been
downplaying uh some accounts from ground
commanders involved
in the evacuation of afghanistan over
the past week we heard a state
department spokesperson say that their
criticism was cherry picked from a
larger report for president biden
himself reject those accounts jen uh
last week i believe said that there was
no after-action report so two questions
i wanted to ask you to clarify the white
house position one
does the white house agree
uh that the uh evacuation should have
become or should have been started
earlier which is what some senior
military officials have asserted and
secondly did jen misspeak last week when
she said there was no after-action
report there's been some reporting from
a colleague of mine over the weekend
that indicated there was indeed an
after-action report that was reviewed so
to your last question no jen did not
misspeak last week uh this abbey gate
report is not the pentagon's broader
action border broader after action
review on afghanistan that report will
examine the final months
of america's longest war and cover from
february 2020 through the end of the
evacuation so no she did not misspeak
but let me just say something uh that i
think is really important i'm just going
to quote john kirby who was uh who did a
sunday show yesterday i believe this was
a fox news sunday show and i'll quote
him here he said i would i would also
add here in washington we have been
planning for evacuation as far back as
april and there was no effort by
washington certainly not by the national
security council specifically to slow
down that planning to slow down those
pre-positioning of forces that we did in
the summer to slow down the actual
execution of the evacuation so again
this is john kirby
spokesperson for the department of
defense so again these were documents
that assert impressions and perspectives
which are very important down at the
tactical level in real time we need to
conduct a larger more strategic level
level after action review to get the
whole sense of this and we're doing that
the abbey report again is one important
review of what occurred that day but it
should not be mistaken for a full
follow-up on the last months of the of
the war in afghanistan
on a different topic to follow up on the
earlier questions about the supreme
court i know you said that the president
has not uh conducted any interviews with
candidates yet but does the white house
will the white house disclose
which candidates the president does
interviews with as he goes through this
process what i can promise you right now
is that the pro the president's going to
make his selection uh for the supreme
court justice by the end of this month
that's what we know that's what he
stated uh and that's what we will do and
last question uh
vice president harris is headed abroad
to the munich security conference this
week can you talk a little bit about
what the white house hopes she will
accomplish there and is she going to be
sort of the sole representative of the
administration in some of these meetings
with counterparts are there going to be
other
administration officials as well can you
sort of give us a sense of what the
expectation is so i don't have any
specifics but i can say that we are very
proud to have the vice president lead
the delegation uh to to munich this week
i don't have any specific details i'm
happy to talk to the team to see exactly
what her schedule is going to look like
but where we are the president is proud
that she's going to be representing the
united states
okay there's a couple of quick ones
following up on this zelinski question
can you confirm whether president
zielinski asked president biden to come
to ukraine this week and whether the
administration considered it at all i
know you don't have travel to announce
but
all i can tell you is what i just said
we don't have travel to to confirm uh
right now that is uh what this
president's schedule looks like uh in
the it's certainly not confirming to to
go to visit ukraine uh
and that's what now our focus right now
is to continue to have the uh the
conversations on the staff level uh to
continue to make sure that we are we'll
keep that the door to diplomacy open uh
there's too much at stake there are
human lives at stake which is what the
president uh told president putin and
and that is our focus how do we stop a
war that's our focus pfizer withdrew
late last week it's application for the
vaccine for young kids is that a
disappointment to the white house
so
fda is committed to acting urgently to
save lives amidst the pandemic and they
continue to work with pfizer to review
additional data on its vaccine for kids
under five in recent days new data as as
you know tam emerged
regarding pfizer submission to the fda
for its vaccine for kids under five
years old based on fda's assessment of
that new data the agency concluded that
additional information regarding a third
dose should be considered as part of any
authorization the initial data has been
helpful to the process
but fda believes more information
including uh the impact of a third dose
is important to the evaluation so that
is the process that that is the process
uh right now currently uh that's that
that's working and that should give
parents everywhere confidence in the
process right because we want to make
sure that the process is working
fda is in the middle of a of a thorough
independent regulatory process to review
this vaccine and if a vaccine is
authorized it will have met fda's
rigorous standards so that is what the
parents as a parent myself and i know
your parents should be uh really uh very
proud of that the fda is doing this and
on the dc mass mandate do you expect
that mass mandate coming down to affect
policy here on campus at the white house
so as always if we say this local
communities will make their own
decisions uh as they have throughout the
pandemic and and we'll but what we're
going to do is we're going to abide by
the cdc guidance so that is local
communities make that decision uh and
that is what they choose to do the white
house is not following
the local guidelines we're following
this place that is in the city to be
clear we are going to follow the cdc
guidance that's what we're going to do
go ahead
back to the vp's trip to germany
is there discussion in the white house
about whether she should go no matter
what is happening in ukraine or has
there been discussions about what might
trigger her to cancel you know i i don't
have uh any
any insight on that that's another
hypothetical that i can't answer
but what i can say is that we are proud
that she is going to be
leading the u.s delegation
to munich and and that is on on schedule
to happen on the embassy
do you know all the classified
information has now been stripped from
that building i i do not have that
information for you
yeah
okay thank you i want to ask you a few
questions
do you think countries are endless
can you say can you say that one more
time
japan india and australia they had a
meeting in australia
do you think these countries are
unanimous on the on the russian
russian issue in particular so as you
know secretary blinken was just in the
region where he met with the quad uh it
was an opportunity to discuss russia's
ongoing threat to ukraine they discussed
the threat that russia's aggression
poses not only to ukraine but to the
entire international rules based uh
based order which has provided a
foundation for decades of shared
security and prosperity
for the region and around the globe
throughout his meetings with the quad
partners secretary blinken discussed the
challenges russia poses to the rules
based uh based on international order
and our readiness to support our
european allies
i'm asking this question because you
know that india's foreign external press
minister s der schenker
said that india only follows
multilateral sanctions not country
especially questions and as you're
looking towards
uh current specific sanctions from the
u.s because the u.s equity council is
unlikely to go for those sanctions
because the vetoes russia and china have
that
are even conversations and indians that
they should follow the u.s sanctions as
well
um so you know we're not going to get
into specifics we've been really clear
about our discussions uh so not going
into details on that but beyond what
we've read out from the secretary's
meeting in melbourne last week but we're
working closely with a range of allies
and partners including india one final
question what role
president biden expects india to play in
the court
so we will continue to build a strategic
partnership in which the united states
and india
work together to promote stability in
south asia
collaborate in new domains such as
health space cyberspace which is
important deepen our economic and
technology cooperation and contribute to
a free and open indo-specific we
recognize that india is a like-minded
partner and leader in in south asia and
the indian ocean
active in and connected to the southeast
asia a driving force of the quad and an
engine for regional growth and
development
no problem oh thank you
thanks everybody
don't forget to get those flowers
there's candy